Caption: good afternoon everyone and welcome to
Caption: one of two panels we've got going today
Caption: this one is the ask me anything panel uh
Caption: if you hadn't read that on the screen
Caption: already if you were looking for our
Caption: inclusive working panel I suggest you
Caption: have a look in the billia or river room
Caption: at the other end of the building
Caption: I'd like to take a quick
Caption: moment to again thank the wonderful
Caption: sponsors that have helped put on D2D
Caption: Perth this year without them we really
Caption: couldn't bring all these wonderful talks
Caption: food everything to you here today
Caption: and with that I would like to introduce
Caption: you to today's panel we have four
Caption: wonderful speakers here today and I will
Caption: let them introduce themselves you would
Caption: have met some of them already
Caption: starting with Christina
Caption: I'm Christina Aldan I am a brand
Caption: strategy consultant based in Las Vegas I
Caption: work for a runner software I'm a speaker
Caption: trainer Mentor I'm a soon to be author
Caption: and it's my first time in Perth and I
Caption: took a selfie with a quokka yesterday so
Caption: like I'm good like whatever happens from
Caption: there is amazing
Caption: and next up we have Sam price
Caption: hello everyone
Caption: I guess at heart I'm a bit of a techie
Caption: so I've had a a lot of different roles
Caption: in Tech over the last 20 years a
Caption: software engineer architect manager
Caption: um now I'm currently a VP of engineering
Caption: at Family Zone cyber safety but um yeah
Caption: super happy to be here today and it's
Caption: amazing to see such a turnout so thanks
Caption: everyone and thanks to all the speakers
Caption: and sponsors
Caption: and next up we have Julie Grundy
Caption: hi there
Caption: um yeah my name is Julie Grundy I'm a
Caption: senior digital accessibility consultant
Caption: at intopia and head of audit practice so
Caption: for the last however long I've been
Caption: training people in accessibility mostly
Caption: Dev teams
Caption: and auditing people including some big
Caption: corporations art projects uh everything
Caption: in between and in my copious quantities
Caption: of free time I also organize part of
Caption: organizing the local Perth web
Caption: accessibility camp
Caption: and finally we have saradalay
Caption: brother and I'm a co-founder of perfect
Caption: machine learning group
Caption: our goal is to increase the capability
Caption: of AI and machine learning in Perth our
Caption: members have come from different
Caption: background from government Academia and
Caption: Industry so we so far have offered to
Caption: 1800s remember now so hopefully continue
Caption: to grow I used to work in consultancy
Caption: helping companies to do the AI work and
Caption: now I focus on medical research using
Caption: computer vision for digital pathologies
Caption: so thank you very much to our four
Caption: panelists uh my name is David Miko I'm
Caption: your chair for this panel for the rest
Caption: of the session here today and I just
Caption: briefly want to mention slido which is
Caption: the platform that you can go to if you
Caption: haven't already to interact with the
Caption: panel today ask some questions have a
Caption: look at the questions that have already
Caption: been asked upvote them and that's the
Caption: way that you can interact with these
Caption: fine folks on stage today
Caption: but given that we only have half an hour
Caption: let's kick straight into it
Caption: and our first question which I'm sure is
Caption: very topical uh given the market at the
Caption: moment
Caption: what's the software developer employment
Caption: ecosystem like at the moment if you're
Caption: wanting to hire a full-time developer do
Caption: you recruit locally do you recruit
Caption: overseas do you recruit remotely
Caption: Sam you're a VP of engineering you do a
Caption: lot of recruitment what's your take on
Caption: this
Caption: so I think it really depends on the size
Caption: of the organization and the maturity of
Caption: the process processes
Caption: so particularly if you were to consider
Caption: the really small and a text startup
Caption: they're going to be very Dynamic it's
Caption: going to be a very fast-paced
Caption: environment so managing a like highly
Caption: remote or overseas particularly when
Caption: time zones are involved our Workforce is
Caption: going to be extremely challenging and
Caption: not really lead to the business outcomes
Caption: that are required at that stage for that
Caption: institution on the other hand on the
Caption: other hand if you're if the companies
Caption: like Google or I know any other kind of
Caption: large organization are more likely to
Caption: have rigorous process in place and
Caption: better support for people so I think
Caption: it's sort of a bit of a balancing act so
Caption: I think the larger organizations are
Caption: going to be more readily able to
Caption: remotely hire and then I think you know
Caption: in the middle there's probably a bit of
Caption: a mix and a bit of a balance
Caption: thank you very much uh on to a extremely
Caption: popular question next
Caption: should I add nfts or crypto to my
Caption: software project
Caption: Julie if you do it accessibly I guess
Caption: that's acceptable
Caption: uh rather Christina I believe we talked
Caption: about this last night what's what's your
Caption: thoughts on this matter
Caption: um I do a lot of startup advising and
Caption: I'm going to say what advice I usually
Caption: give them so you know if you have
Caption: something attached to
Caption: somebody who's really popular it's a
Caption: celebrity it's something like that you
Caption: can trade it you can sell it you can
Caption: quickly turn it over it's while it still
Caption: holds its value then yes absolutely
Caption: if not then it's just too risky
Caption: especially for like I said startups who
Caption: are starting these new projects or or
Caption: people who maybe don't even quite
Caption: understand how data are transferred
Caption: along the way and the lifetime and the
Caption: sustainability of it I have somebody
Caption: that I worked with in fact who sits he's
Caption: like chairman of the board they formed a
Caption: nft commission now in Las Vegas and he's
Caption: a chairman and um he yeah I put this art
Caption: in here well okay but you put an art for
Caption: a famous artist that has significant
Caption: value already a lot of people that are
Caption: coming to him are having issues because
Caption: after people pass they can't access
Caption: their nft they can't access their stuff
Caption: and there's not a system in place for
Caption: that and that's a lot of money that
Caption: that's been lost we also in that same
Caption: ecosystem had a basketball player who
Caption: took in like two and a half million
Caption: dollars on their Discord server and then
Caption: one day he said you know what
Caption: this is just really stressful I'm
Caption: shutting everything down anybody who put
Caption: in fifteen hundred dollars I'm just
Caption: going to give you a signed jersey and
Caption: thanks for playing and he took their 2.3
Caption: million dollars and left and it's
Caption: there's no repercussions for that and
Caption: all of the kids that had looked up for
Caption: to him who didn't have the money to
Caption: invest in in what he was offering they
Caption: invested it anyway because he's like
Caption: they're cool Idol he took their money
Caption: and left and and those kids you know
Caption: they they can't get that money back so
Caption: um I I think that if you can turn it
Caption: over quickly and if it's attached to
Caption: something that's high value and you can
Caption: get that value and extract it you know
Caption: within 12 months or so then it would be
Caption: worth it otherwise I don't I don't see
Caption: the the use for that we have another
Caption: startup who's trying to attach uh grades
Caption: in schools to follow uh the the child
Caption: and their progression through their to
Caption: college and I just don't think that's
Caption: sustainable the amount of energy and
Caption: effort that's that's required to to
Caption: track all of that it's just it's not
Caption: there
Caption: and I think it's environmentally
Caption: irresponsible
Caption: well Samantha okay another really big
Caption: question
Caption: where will machine learning have the
Caption: biggest impact in the next 10 years
Caption: Serrata
Caption: um it's a very tough question even we
Caption: will look back in Alaska last couple
Caption: months
Caption: we have such a big big flow in
Caption: generative area so I even can't imagine
Caption: how the world going to be in the next
Caption: few months so looking into you can just
Caption: type in a simple
Caption: um text message to describe the scene
Caption: and the computer can completely generate
Caption: for you and also recently just have a
Caption: competition and the Machine already
Caption: beaten the human so all these changes
Caption: um can be scary and I think one of the
Caption: speakers also talking about the defect
Caption: so I think we really need to worry about
Caption: the social impacts on what is Bill was
Caption: what is not real and for the longer
Caption: Horizons I really want to see the
Caption: medical research continue to improve and
Caption: have a big impact for our health
Caption: from I think it's more the regulatory to
Caption: catch up the technology rather than the
Caption: the dialysis on its own but I really
Caption: want to see that have a better
Caption: improvement in our health system
Caption: all right thank you very much
Caption: I'm going to throw this next one to
Caption: Julie
Caption: so what's the first thing that you look
Caption: for when doing an accessibility audit
Caption: what do you do when you're building
Caption: something new
Caption: so if I'm looking just starting out a
Caption: fresh audit the first thing that I
Caption: always look at is I open up devtools and
Caption: the elements panel and I look at the
Caption: quality of the HTML
Caption: that tells you a lot about where to
Caption: pitch the rest of the testing and the
Caption: verification because good good quality
Caption: HTML is the the basis of what goes into
Caption: our accessibility API and then gets
Caption: passed on to assistive technology so you
Caption: can learn so much from that part if I'm
Caption: testing I generally test heading
Caption: structure first because that has a
Caption: benefit for so many people
Caption: uh if I'm building something fresh I do
Caption: again start with that HTML
Caption: um we sort of sometimes talk about the
Caption: accessibility stack uh being HTML CSS
Caption: JavaScript and Aria it's a purely
Caption: front-end stack and it's less of a stack
Caption: and more of a pyramid with HTML giving
Caption: you so much accessibility for free that
Caption: if you get that right then everything
Caption: else that you're doing is just enhancing
Caption: and making more usable and extending to
Caption: a wider range of people but that that
Caption: Bedrock if I could give one piece of
Caption: accessibility advice to people who don't
Caption: have time to learn accessibility
Caption: learn HTML really really get into those
Caption: mdn
Caption: definitions and really get to know it
Caption: really well
Caption: okay thank you very much I think this
Caption: next one is a great question
Caption: um and I I might actually throw it open
Caption: to the panel to see
Caption: um maybe if there's multiple insights on
Caption: it but how do you convince your company
Caption: to care about privacy and I assume from
Caption: this perspective we're talking about the
Caption: privacy of its customers
Caption: I'm actually going to jump in here and
Caption: say without being a privacy expert I
Caption: have had experience with trying to get
Caption: organizations to care about
Caption: accessibility which along with security
Caption: is one of those things that seems a bit
Caption: nebulous and fuzzy and how do you know
Caption: when you're doing it well but everybody
Caption: puts it off to care about later after
Caption: they've shipped
Caption: we tend to go for you you kind of need a
Caption: Grassroots kind of level of support and
Caption: often that comes from one person taking
Caption: it on and becoming a champion but not
Caption: telling other people off for doing it
Caption: wrong but more praising them when they
Caption: get it right and
Caption: um
Caption: being a bit pesty in meetings about
Caption: um like oh yes this is an accessibility
Caption: issue I assume you could do the same
Caption: with privacy this is a privacy issue we
Caption: should absolutely be thinking about this
Caption: now
Caption: and then buttonhole the people in charge
Caption: and harass them into caring because you
Caption: will not leave them alone until they do
Caption: this sounds very informal but it's been
Caption: a winning formula for many many large
Caption: organizations
Caption: this is being recorded being sent out so
Caption: sorry to my clients
Caption: I can chew in a little bit as well
Caption: because I deal with medical data so um
Caption: it's in view in the organization level
Caption: they're already aware the importance of
Caption: the privacy but from the development
Caption: side we also concerned about we put it
Caption: on the cloud service where's the
Caption: location
Caption: um we share the responsibility make sure
Caption: we have the white assets so and also
Caption: reminding them your your boss if they
Caption: fail to do it they will have a big fight
Caption: on the gdpr so yeah they will make the
Caption: decision
Caption: yeah it's great I think it's a great oh
Caption: Sam thanks yeah
Caption: um this is a kind of funny one but
Caption: I think
Caption: like what as Julie said
Caption: um
Caption: if you can hire someone whose
Caption: responsibility it is to really focus on
Caption: privacy and keep up to date particularly
Caption: from a legal perspective and what that
Caption: means to your organization and that's
Caption: sort of a huge win but then obviously
Caption: getting executive support in that and
Caption: really creating a culture so privacy
Caption: really is a cultural issue so it's
Caption: making everyone understand what it means
Caption: but to customers and what it means like
Caption: what's stored in data and then rather
Caption: than I guess to use a
Caption: perhaps important but rather than to
Caption: bore people with legal jargon it's
Caption: really great if you've got that champion
Caption: or sort of I guess ambassador to
Caption: um sort of
Caption: re-relay what it means to individual
Caption: teams and how that like provides simple
Caption: patterns for how that they can approach
Caption: privacy in their day-to-day work
Caption: yeah great input from all of our
Caption: panelists there I'm going to change
Caption: gears slightly here and move more to
Caption: individual development and the way that
Caption: that's aligned in the market right now
Caption: um
Caption: what's the best thing that I can invest
Caption: in outside of work to make myself
Caption: attractive to an employer
Caption: do a lot of career mentorship for
Caption: developers specifically and about how to
Caption: lead from within and so an investment
Caption: really is in yourself and making
Caption: yourself look attractive and the way
Caption: that we do that is by helping other
Caption: people and lifting them up you build a
Caption: community around you you build a a tribe
Caption: of of advocates for yourself and so
Caption: they're going to be allies they're going
Caption: to be supporters they're going to be
Caption: sponsors and you become
Caption: um you know this brand that is
Caption: essentially somebody who is a leader now
Caption: you already have a brand whether you
Caption: want to admit it or not right so as
Caption: you're sitting in your team you already
Caption: are represented representing certain
Caption: values you are representing how you
Caption: present a how you are showing up in with
Caption: your a dress your appearance your
Caption: attitudes you already have a brand the
Caption: difference of course is that you're just
Caption: going to be more intentional about that
Caption: brand so I would advise everybody to go
Caption: home and think about your top three to
Caption: five core values that make you tick and
Caption: then start making your choices your
Caption: decisions start living your life around
Caption: those those core values what's going to
Caption: happen is you start to attract other
Caption: people who share those core values those
Caption: people like what you have they want to
Caption: start doing what you do and in fact
Caption: they're going to lift you up when they
Caption: recognize somebody else doing those
Caption: things oh you should go talk to to Joe
Caption: because you know Joe does that he loves
Caption: that you should go talk to Susie Susie
Caption: loves doing that and so suddenly you
Caption: start to create this brand for yourself
Caption: and then you know decide to pick two
Caption: different platforms to put that content
Caption: out that represent your brand maybe it's
Caption: tick tock maybe it's Facebook maybe it's
Caption: just one-on-one speaking with people
Caption: because that's that's what works for you
Caption: maybe you send out some press releases I
Caption: don't know but you can create yourself
Caption: as a brand and you can lead within from
Caption: within you don't have to be a leader you
Caption: don't have to have a title
Caption: um because at the end of the day you
Caption: already have a reputation so it's up to
Caption: you to kind of guide those conversations
Caption: and around that that reputation
Caption: thank you very much Christina
Caption: so let's say I've built my brand and
Caption: I've got my job
Caption: so in Perth right now
Caption: salaries are
Caption: you know growing there's a bit of a
Caption: certainly been a lot of heat in the
Caption: market so to speak
Caption: so I might throw this to Sam first but
Caption: is this just a bubble like is this just
Caption: a temporary thing should I be concerned
Caption: if I'm an engineer in the market right
Caption: now
Caption: uh that's a good question I don't have
Caption: the crystal ball I think that might be
Caption: tiny bit of a bubble but realistically
Caption: it's my own personal take is that we
Caption: don't really need to worry too much
Caption: about that but just rather focus on
Caption: ourselves and focus on on our work and
Caption: really
Caption: um
Caption: yeah make sure that we're we're being
Caption: our best Mis and and I think we'll we'll
Caption: be okay
Caption: on a somewhat related note
Caption: so if you're a graduate and you're
Caption: entering the market right now
Caption: um it's obviously a bit different for
Caption: than how it would be a few years ago
Caption: even given covert and remote work and
Caption: and things like that
Caption: does the panel think that we're able to
Caption: give grads enough support in their early
Caption: years in the industry at the moment
Caption: thank you
Caption: Christina what do you think
Caption: um I think that if your communication
Caption: processes and the way that you're
Caption: organizing in your teams is done well
Caption: with diversity equity and inclusion then
Caption: that's not really an issue people can
Caption: still feel connected as long as we are
Caption: creating systems that allow them to be
Caption: connected in multiple different ways and
Caption: so having
Caption: diverse voices that feel like they're
Caption: being heard if if you have that already
Caption: then you don't have to worry about it
Caption: that's that's not really an issue I have
Caption: many friends who lead remote teams all
Caption: over the world that are have never even
Caption: met in person and they're very
Caption: successful and they're very connected
Caption: and sometimes when they do meet up at
Caption: conferences their besties and it's
Caption: awesome because they already are very
Caption: familiar with what's going on in each
Caption: other's lives they have multiple ways
Caption: for communicating and the Nuance in that
Caption: has to be prioritized the new one months
Caption: of communication has to be prioritized
Caption: through documentation through multiple
Caption: ways of communicating and through
Caption: respect
Caption: okay great answer
Caption: I might throw the next one to Serato if
Caption: I'm an application developer but I want
Caption: to move into working with AI or ml
Caption: how best is it to make that move how do
Caption: I start
Caption: Ed you don't need to pay for anything
Caption: from the resources you want to learn
Caption: from to the computer power there is no
Caption: excuse not to learn and I can point you
Caption: to a perfect machine learning group and
Caption: I follow on Farsi ISL I did it myself
Caption: and I continue following I I just enjoy
Caption: every moment
Caption: all the new technology what I can apply
Caption: for it's just so exciting the world is
Caption: changing so fast but in a in a good way
Caption: so come and join us or chat with me
Caption: afterwards so I can point you to some
Caption: resources and fast AI is fantastic
Caption: community and that's a lot of
Caption: opportunity to contribute to open source
Caption: environment so it also can help you to
Caption: prepare yourself for your next move
Caption: okay I think the next one is a probably
Caption: a good one to throw uh over to
Caption: well anyone on the panel really but I
Caption: might start with Julie because we were
Caption: talking about
Caption: um flying around the place last night
Caption: number of the panelists here have you
Caption: know flown around the world and talked
Caption: in various cities Jacob asks is the
Caption: Perth technology sector lacking anything
Caption: in particular compared to the eastern
Caption: states or overseas right now or is in
Caption: the era of remote work is that not
Caption: really an issue
Caption: yeah we were talking about this last
Caption: night I I'm incredibly biased on this
Caption: though in that I don't think that the
Caption: Perth sector if there is if there are
Caption: gaps and I'm sure people can identify
Caption: them I don't think that there's anything
Caption: lacking in our capability or our
Caption: capacity to grow and fill those gaps in
Caption: terms of working remotely uh intopia is
Caption: a fully distributed organization so I'm
Caption: the only employee in Perth but we have
Caption: people all around Australia in New
Caption: Zealand in America and in Canada and in
Caption: general we've found the quality of
Caption: people that we find to be pretty similar
Caption: all around so again I'm the only one in
Caption: Perth until Loren came to visit us so
Caption: um
Caption: yeah I I might be incredibly biased on
Caption: that but I do think that there is a lot
Caption: of strength and a lot of resilience and
Caption: creativity in Perth so if there's any
Caption: particular language sets or skill sets
Caption: that are missing I think that's just a
Caption: case of okay fine we identify them and
Caption: we fill those gaps
Caption: but I'll pass over to people who are
Caption: possibly less biased
Caption: yeah I think it's
Caption: um sort of just a function of our
Caption: population really so I think we've got
Caption: everything just in smaller amounts and
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: like on a daily day for me is one of
Caption: those little Sparks in the the Perth
Caption: sort of tech scene
Caption: um
Caption: I'd love to see more investment in Tech
Caption: and more startups and growth here and
Caption: more conferences like this one
Caption: um but yeah I don't think there's any
Caption: fundamental lack of skills I just think
Caption: it's a functionality sorry just a
Caption: function of us being a comparatively
Caption: small and in a relatively isolated part
Caption: of the world
Caption: Okay so we've got about five minutes
Caption: left I'm going to jump around to a few
Caption: fun ones here that I've gotten the list
Caption: what's a boring technology that people
Caption: or companies should use more forget
Caption: about web3 and blockchain for a moment
Caption: what's something boring we should look
Caption: at
Caption: embracing my mic to my mouth to get in
Caption: first HTML
Caption: it's the handy dandy go anywhere
Caption: do anything kind of Swiss army knife as
Caption: far as boring Tech goes HTML is actually
Caption: pretty bloody great
Caption: look out throw out one
Caption: um any any of the languages that are
Caption: used for infrastructure as code so cloud
Caption: formation does anyone like yaml
Caption: um
Caption: HCL for terraform I don't know I'm
Caption: probably going to get murdered by a few
Caption: people after this fellow
Caption: those kinds of things but we need to do
Caption: more infrastructure as code
Caption: for me I don't know SQL so I I know
Caption: people will
Caption: disagree with me but for me
Caption: um
Caption: when I have an interview and people ask
Caption: me my skill or SQL I I can do other
Caption: things using other languages I don't
Caption: like SQL and also it's an indicator for
Caption: me that will be a very boring and very
Caption: dirty job I am also doing the cleaning
Caption: more than doing the machine learning so
Caption: SQL for me is the dirty words
Caption: okay has anyone got a fun War Story to
Caption: share from the last year
Caption: in what context
Caption: not any that my clients would be happy
Caption: for me to have recorded
Caption: many War Stories but none that are fun
Caption: I think I think we've all been there
Caption: okay uh
Caption: well here's a uh here's something that's
Caption: a little bit different
Caption: what is the meaning of life as a
Caption: developer in your eyes and bearing in
Caption: mind that we all know that the answer is
Caption: 42 uh what else do you think the meaning
Caption: of life as a developer is Christina yes
Caption: I'm super excited to answer this I work
Caption: Ed really really hard with my mentees to
Caption: teach them creative problem solving
Caption: because it's all about critical thinking
Caption: and solving problems a lot of times the
Caption: people that I work with just enjoy
Caption: working on things and chewing on things
Caption: and a lot of times they like the
Caption: accolades as well and for me I try to
Caption: help shift them to the empathetic side
Caption: right I'm the emotional intelligence
Caption: woman so I'm always looking at how we
Caption: connect our products and services with
Caption: empathy with kindness and with
Caption: Innovation to to the people that are are
Caption: using them and I try to
Caption: in part into people that those creative
Caption: problem solving skills those thinking
Caption: skills that often come so naturally to
Caption: people in our industry and they're very
Caption: very valuable and and you can sometimes
Caption: just take that for granted because
Caption: you're surrounded with other people who
Caption: are doing that but if you think about
Caption: the those problem-solving skills that
Caption: you have and how you can use the tools
Caption: to really work on solving some of these
Caption: difficult challenging problems of the
Caption: world that has a deep and and greater
Caption: purpose
Caption: that's a fantastic answer so I'm gonna
Caption: I'm gonna end on one I'm gonna ask
Caption: um each of our panelists this question
Caption: uh because it is the most popular
Caption: question on left on the app right now
Caption: we've covered a little bit already so
Caption: I'm gonna I'm gonna Riff on it a little
Caption: bit so the original question asks what's
Caption: the hype with web3 it feels like it's a
Caption: waste of time and money and has no value
Caption: I'll extend that a little bit
Caption: one of the things we criticize about as
Caption: technologists is we get distracted by
Caption: the next sort of shiny thing
Caption: how do we distinguish the next shiny
Caption: thing from something that actually has
Caption: value how do we actually dig in and
Caption: understand whether that has value Sam
Caption: I'll start with you and then we'll go
Caption: around the panel
Caption: it's a very good question
Caption: um
Caption: I'd like to believe that everything has
Caption: value and that the current form is
Caption: likely to to change over time but there
Caption: are some underlying principles and so
Caption: it's really just finding that sort of
Caption: almost like product Market fit where
Caption: there's an evolution and so what we see
Caption: now is might be hard to really
Caption: understand what it's going to look like
Caption: in the future but I wouldn't be
Caption: surprised if we we see something that
Caption: resembles not the web 3 of today but you
Caption: know a particular application going
Caption: forward but certainly right now I can
Caption: understand why people would be feeling a
Caption: bit dubious about it
Caption: um I definitely agree with Sam about the
Caption: pot and Margaret fit and then adding
Caption: value to the problem but that means we
Caption: actually really need the domain expert
Caption: to understand the problem and apply the
Caption: technology technology is a set should be
Caption: a second secondary rather than the
Caption: primary we should more always focus on
Caption: solving the problem and at Value to the
Caption: situation the cat is shiny and next day
Caption: they were gone so even the language we
Caption: learned today may be not applicable in
Caption: couple of years so don't hang on to the
Caption: technology focused on the problem and
Caption: solving it
Caption: I think there is a small part of the
Caption: community that is going to enjoy
Caption: spending time with their their goggles
Caption: on right and there are already people in
Caption: the metaverse who really like certain
Caption: things and and that's where they find
Caption: connection and that's great and it's a
Caption: certain subset of the population and so
Caption: I think for that it does have value
Caption: right for people who it's valuable if
Caption: you have skins if you if you can buy
Caption: certain things if you can have okay yeah
Caption: we want to put some effort I can
Caption: understand how companies want to do
Caption: marketing within the metaverse and stuff
Caption: like that I get it but you know the
Caption: reality is is that it's like 10 000
Caption: people own a third of the crypto and I
Caption: mean at that point and and there's
Caption: something like 50 of the wallet keys are
Caption: lost like you never will ever see them
Caption: again and so with that level there's
Caption: really it's it's not really practical
Caption: for like me what's what's the the
Caption: motivation for me to get into that when
Caption: there's there's ten thousand people who
Caption: are already going to hold it there's a
Caption: small percentage of of the population
Caption: that's holding it and then what happens
Caption: is we end up having all of these other
Caption: kids again who can't afford it this is
Caption: um and they're they're spending a lot of
Caption: money and they're doing it wrong you can
Caption: do it right though I have mentees who
Caption: paid off their mom's entire house it was
Caption: you know they had a 65 000 mortgage loan
Caption: and these kids paid it off playing
Caption: Esports games they're amazing
Caption: um I I have other people who are using
Caption: it to their advantage for testing things
Caption: or for um training during remote teams
Caption: um you know that's that's a good use of
Caption: it will it take over our future and oh
Caption: my gosh everybody's going to be into
Caption: this and we all have to jump to the next
Caption: shiny thing no I I don't think so no
Caption: I yeah tend to agree with everybody here
Caption: um my own thinking on this is very much
Caption: about how when I first started learning
Caption: to make websites it was very much like
Caption: I can I have I can make a thing and put
Caption: it out in the world and other people can
Caption: just show up and look at it and we don't
Caption: need Rupert Murdoch's permission to do
Caption: so a lot of the extra hype comes from
Caption: people inserting themselves as a
Caption: middleman in a process so that they can
Caption: extract a profit
Caption: um I think the real longevity and
Caption: promise of
Caption: computing and software and the internet
Caption: comes from those underlying patterns and
Caption: principles of openness transparency
Caption: interoperability and so if those are the
Caption: patterns and principles that you're
Caption: working with and then you learn a
Caption: language that lets you work with that to
Caption: solve the problem that you have and then
Caption: some business people can come along and
Caption: think about Market propositions or
Caption: something maybe that's just I'm just too
Caption: much of a nerd to care about that
Caption: um I'm lucky to have one of one of my
Caption: bosses cares about that very much and he
Caption: thinks about that and I don't have to
Caption: worry about it
Caption: um but I think if anyone is thinking
Caption: about how do you getting back to that
Caption: question about how do you decide between
Caption: what's worth your time learning versus
Caption: what's going to be a flash in the pan I
Caption: think I will recommend a talk given here
Caption: in Perth a few years back at a mixing
Caption: called Full stack anxiety full stack
Caption: anxiety by Joel Khalifa and I found that
Caption: talk really useful to me in mapping out
Caption: where I am now
Caption: the goals I want to have the kinds of
Caption: things I want to build and what skills
Caption: do I need to learn to reach that goal so
Caption: if that's for anyone it is on YouTube
Caption: and you should be able to get a hold of
Caption: it so maybe if that's a concern for you
Caption: give that talk a well
Caption: thank you very much well with that we
Caption: have run a couple of minutes over so
Caption: it's time to break and find our next
Caption: sessions but I would ask first that the
Caption: audience gives our panelists a big round
Caption: of applause
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so thank you everyone that concludes our
Caption: panel and our next sessions will be
Caption: starting at 3 15.